how can we make sure
that you
don't
run for government so you can still do
the great things that you're doing well
because people are gonna [ __ ] beg you
to do it i think i've gotta watch the
old ego same as you check it
it's not going well it's out of control
i'm going out wearing nighttime clothes
for southern belles
i'm dressed like a tennessee williams
heroine and a wrestler combined
i mean i suppose how how i'm gonna do it
is like i remember this like this is
what i fundamentally believe is that
those are sort of systems with an apex
person like you know presidents prime
minister monarchs that's not
representative the centralization of
power is not a solution so if like this
happened before in our country i did
when i've done that jeremy paxman thing
mate like like there was a lot of
suddenly a lot of heat and i'd say stuff
there's no point voting you'll get the
same sort of party anyway they're all
paid for in corporate interest it's all
[ __ ] right and it really blew up and
they talked about me in the houses of
parliament in our country and all of
that and what i should have what should
the thought was oh this is amazing i'm
voicing things that a lot of people are
feeling and i did feel that for a while
and then i thought you're really
important russell and what do you think
is important then it went all wrong it
vibrated too quickly and i span off out
of the road so like uh yeah i won't i'm
not going to do that again in a sense
how do all of us manage the challenge of
knowing that we are infantisimous
in well perhaps by not being able to
pronounce a single word
but this is yeah this is the dark [ __ ]
that go go go no that you are
infinitesimally small yes but also that
all reality is held within your
consciousness there is nothing that you
are aware of that you do not know about
like or whether it's the big bang or the
dinosaurs or political assassinations or
quantum physics all of that exists
within your individual awareness
no no it's like i think the trickiest
thing about like essentially waking up
and i've seen a lot of celebrities
sometimes suffer this i think jim carrey
suffered from this when he woke up he
got dark when he realized i think his
coping mechanism for the world was well
nothing's important nothing matters and
when you start really believing that you
go
oh [ __ ] well nothing matters well why
should i wake up why should i go to the
grocery store why should i be in a
company
the nihilism is [ __ ] crippling and
there's another side to it which i think
he's at right now which is like okay
nothing matters but life is what we make
of it and we need connectivity we need
relationships we need community it makes
us feel good to help one another and
treat one another good so like but
getting from nihilism to
this is important what a [ __ ] joy it
is that we get to be here a lot of
people don't make that jump that's
[ __ ] tough man but we have to make
that jump andrew and there's a reason to
make it in that that jump is anticipated
in all of the great ideologies in islam
in christianity in buddhism they tell
you this it's an illusion but you have
to participate as if it is real you have
to find the beauty in it you are
creating reality while you are living it
you are god the the the father and i are
one it's like trying to tell you
simultaneously yes it's meaningless but
you invest it with meaning you create
purpose the dow you are the path that
you are walking so in a way jim carrey's
got no excuse for going all dark
he's doing the mask not that one with a
scratchy poster
we want ace ventura not when you go all
scary i mean like jim carrey bonafide of
genius hey like proper old-school
[ __ ] physical comic genius vibrating
on a very very high frequency his
fascination with kaufman a situationist
kaufman's work is about oh my god none
of this is real it's ridiculous we could
just do anything we can make chaos you
can suddenly stop participating in the
sanctioned rules of reality it will fall
apart because it's consensual faith is a
component of the [ __ ] stock exchange
of economics uh as science itself at its
most fundamental levels the level of
quantum physics requires consciousness
and belief in order for it to collapse
between waves and particles you know so
what the challenge we have is to invest
it with meaning while recognizing its
meaningless or as christ says in the
world but not of it and i can see how my
personal opinion i can't on my own i go
[ __ ] mental i go i fall down a hole
into the solipsism and the nihilism i
lose my connection i lose my erection i
become unbearable i become unwearable i
can't live within it i need meaning i
need connection and the only place i can
find it is if i sort of think i [ __ ]
hell andrew's a human being the same as
me he's got the same life as me he's got
that he's got past he's got things he's
having to carry every single person i
look at they're the same as me they've
got to carry on living their life and
you don't seem like that when i'm lost
in my own solipsistic
self-obsessiveness but like that's why
that 12-step stuff's good andrew because
on one level it says awaken awaken to
the fact that your life in the past was
unlivable yeah and now the secret be of
service to others don't live a life you
know and i'm not i by have no means got
this cracked because i still spend a lot
of my time thinking i want this i don't
want that the devotee of my preferences
dedicated to what i want and what i
don't want but thankfully i've got this
[ __ ] system that continually reminds
me why are you thinking about yourself
all the time gives a [ __ ] you're gonna
die you're gonna die it doesn't matter
why wouldn't you run for office
become the elites you hate because
get in the system and change it but good
it's a great question
[Music]
i'm curious your answer but please don't
don't you think that what we should do
is people have to have the ability for
amplification is try and find people
that we think are legit and then like
for them
yes legit sociopaths okay okay what if
we audition them
but what if it's this what if it's like
we
we exercise our demands
to a point where they have to fulfill
them they being the elites are they
being the people that are controlled and
i think that's the only way to make
change right is that we just go we want
this thing so i loved the idea of not
voting
if everybody not voted if we didn't vote
in mass it would be the loudest way to
say this system is not working for us
there's two parties
don't they want us to not vote in
america isn't that the whole thing right
now no no they don't they want their
people to vote they want old people to
vote republicans want old people to vote
right liberals want their people to vote
it's that's who we want to vote we want
the other side enough if everybody's
like yo this electoral college is
[ __ ] stupid nothing is actually going
to get done you're all the same and
everybody was like we're not voting it
would be so globally embarrassing that
things would have to change at the very
least yeah and particularly if you
coupled that with don't vote don't pay
back any of your debts like stop paying
all debts or immediately stop paying all
taxes one person
10 000 100 000 people stop paying join
this movement we're not doing our
nihilistic selfishness it's not just
some libertarian whim to save a little
bit of cash back on our atm this is
we're not cooperating with your system
anymore yeah like your economic systems
are faith-based these are out and i like
the use of the word demands because it's
gangster but it should be a manifest
though
oh should it be in america we're not
allowed to say that we're not saying
manifest though because all right
constitution new constitution
no constitution say like you know like
in fact the principles are already
enshrined just do the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's already written down allow people
to have control of their own communities
control of their own lives allow people
to like be there has been no vision in
politics i think since the death of the
great ideas of the last century since
the death of captain of fascism and
communism no one is saying this is how
we could live you can organize and run
your own lives people don't think that
they could be spending their time in
leisure we're all defined by our work
our education systems are about
preparation for the labor market you're
right written off at that point i have a
question about that in terms of spending
your time okay i'm talking about
embarrassing and you're talking about
fight club
let's shame the politicians let's kill
him
i don't see his presence he's like a
dictator i think you do way better
you're drinking gaddafi already like i
feel like you would do it perfect and i
think it ended really well for that
weekend of bernie's jeep ride where they
jostled his dead body about it
am i still in charge of female security
you know what i mean that was his issue
that was his whole thing he only had hot
models
like that's not going to work you know
have you ever seen like a colonel
gaddafi addressing like some
arab summit where it's like all the
leaders of the arabian nations they're
going listen we need to [ __ ] step up
because the west's getting proper larry
you know saying like they've killed that
mercedes i don't know who's gonna be
next yeah well we do now yeah yeah yeah
poor old colonel gaddafi jostled along
all naked and dead shouldn't
that's a human being with rights and
feelings i apologize for that but you
did put him in a comedic position when
he said i look like a dictator that's
what we do here
you're the guy who went to mtv dresses
bin laden on september 12th
you get it it was it was too soon
that was too sick had you done it
today's timing it would have killed you
don't do that yet if that was too soon i
apologize again but in hindsight with 20
years pass or whatever pretty funny i
mean yeah
well
nothing else that's exactly the argument
i made in the tribunal
i said in 20 years time there will be
streaming services that will look upon
me as a kind of profit dictator
then who will be laughing